Sarah Paulson Sarah Paulson stepped out
Sunday night to celebrate American
Horror Story Roanoke at PaleyFest in LA
but before the panel et had to get some
scoop on her upcoming movie Ocean's
eight I like to work right I'd rather
worked and sit at home on my expanding
ass it turns out Sarah had a surprising
nickname hon set can I call you long but
Dom you can call me long back doc it's
true I did wear pants that did
communicate along but John did anybody
else have what were the other nicknames
onset are you the only victim uh I think
I'm the only victim of an icky name as
I've said before a lot of us spent a lot
of time not singing Rihanna's songs and
we all sort of covertly were like are
you doing - really yeah you know it was
a lot of collective winking and yeah
everyone was watching out for everybody
in front of RiRi well who wouldn't
because you know as I said before she's
the coolest gal around so you don't want
to the coolest gals around - supreme
doofus Magoo fists in front of Rihanna
you want to keep a little bit of a cool
coat quotient which I bet you could tell
I'm not super 60s black
[Music]